I've got some fantastic video for you
that reminds me of a very interesting
david pakman show viral clip from years
ago what happened over the last few days
is that Vice President Mike Pence showed
up at a diner in Des Moines Iowa called
the Drake diner he stumbled upon a table
where an emergency room doctor
confronted Mike Pence about the Trump
administration's policy on a bunch of
things related to health care and Mike
Pence malfunctioned is the only way I
can describe it he froze up he didn't
know the Trump administration policy he
tried to change the subject and then he
threw in just standard propaganda
disinformation phrases that are used
strategically to stop having to actually
know anything
so this reminded me of the clip that we
did years ago called MIT Romney gets his
ass handed to him by a gay veteran which
now has nearly a million views and it's
a similar setup where at the time Mitt
Romney was running for president he
showed up at some restaurant in New
Hampshire and he approached a guy and it
turned out that the guy was a gay
veteran who confronted Romney on a whole
bunch of issues and it was fantastic
so back to this year and the Drake diner
in Des Moines Iowa this is going to be
sort of another one of these propaganda
disinformation break down type videos
featuring dr. Rob Davidson dr. Rob
Davidson's an emergency room doctor Mike
Pence walks in walks up to dr. Davidson
shakes hands and it very quickly goes
south and you will see Mike Pence
instantly regretting this like the
second dr. Davidson starts talking Pence
is not pleased we're gonna listen to a
few seconds and then notice that when
dr. Davidson says these are the things
you're doing now that are bad pen says
you know when I was governor here a we
did XY and Z that has nothing to do with
Trump administration policy which is
what dr. Davidson is trying to talk
about so this is the first
disinformation technique let's take a
look
feather I'm Joel so that's me mister I'm
worried about maybe cutting Medicare and
then the rollout today of cutting
Medicaid they're working on the poorest
counties in Michigan and my patients
depending on expanded Medicaid so how's
that going to affect medicaid yeah the
the head of CMS announced the plan to
Lester so they could give block grants
so that would essentially cut the amount
of money going to the state's federal
Medicaid funding is that a good idea
so dr. Davidson is talking about right
now and Mike Pence is talking about well
you know when I was governor in Indiana
we did this that or the other thing
so let's now back it up a few seconds
we're gonna pick it back up and the good
doctor does not let Mike Pence get away
with it and says I'm talking about now
I'm not talking about when you were
governor I'm talking about national
policy now that you're the vice
president so dr. Davidson tries it a
second time take a look
right but now they're talking about
scaling back the Medicaid expansion that
they that we got with the Affordable
Care Act and that six hundred eighty
thousand Michigan or six hundred
thousand I know a lot of people got a we
expanded coverage in Indiana right what
I was talking about the president and
your administration right now what
they're doing so Mike Pence again tries
to talk about
who knows what year he's even referring
to and dr. Davidson brings him back the
reality is just that Mike Pence doesn't
know the policy right now he has no idea
what dr. Davidson is talking about and
here's how the conversation ultimately
wrapped up with another technique which
will point out I mean you're just
announced they rub it out today and it's
going to keep across the country cutting
Medicaid I mean is that a good idea I
think it comes down to that for the
people I take care of all the time I
mean people I see in the emergency
department that can't get primary care
doctors you know once they get Medicaid
they can get primary care doctors they
stay out of the ER they actually work
more they actually contributed to our
community more now a couple of people
say this actually by coincidence ends up
being a good example of how to detect BS
and disinformation techniques so let's
go through it Mike Pence first gets
confronted with some facts and he
doesn't really seem to know the fact or
he certainly can't defend what his
administration has been doing so he
changes the subject dr. Davidson's
talking about one thing 20/20 national
health care policy and Mike Pence starts
talking about some year when he was
Indiana governor policy specifically in
Indiana and that's not what dr.
Davidson's trying to talk about it may
or may not be true what Pence is saying
but it's certainly not what's being
discussed right now then pence changes
tactic and he missed States the current
policy so he says well you know it's
waivers or this or that and dr. Davidson
again says now calls them out doesn't
let them get away with that
so then Mike Pence does a wrap
that's similar to let's agree to
disagree now sometimes it's logical to
say let's agree to disagree sometimes in
a conversation with family or friends
you're just you're not gonna get
anywhere else you're not making policy
decisions you just say let's agree to
disagree when an elected official like
Mike Pence uses that or something
similar to it it's a sign that they're
losing and what Mike Pence said was I
think you were oversimplifying that's a
conversation ender similar to let's
agree to disagree may be actually more
pernicious and again
nice job by dr. Rob Davidson and that
lets me get to the fourth tactic dr.
Davidson in a sense has a horse in this
race okay and some people after this
video went viral found out although it's
not a secret that dr. Davidson is
involved with an organization an
organization called the Committee to
Protect Medicare so the forth
disinformation tactic Mike Pence did
three of them number four is actually
being done by right-wingers who just
want to attack dr. Davidson if you look
on the internet the fourth tactic is
this dr. Davidson dude is biased he's
part of a group that wants to protect
Medicare strictly speaking that's an ad
hominem right like yeah of course this
guy has an opinion and Mike Pence has an
opinion dr. Davidson is on a committee
to protect Medicare that doesn't change
the facts that dr. Davidson is asserting
Mike Pence also has a horse in the race
in that his administration he is Trump's
vice president
they have policy that they want to
convince people is good policy so it's
an ad hominem strictly speaking to say
you can't believe Davidson because he's
on a committee that wants to protect
Medicare you know there's a lot of
senior citizens who also want to protect
Medicare are we going to call them all
biased in the exact same way where we
say the facts don't matter no you can
have an opinion and the facts they'll
matter that is a disinformation
technique number four which is discount
the position as irrelevant or not
believable because the person is biased
by having a horse in the race you can
bet your ass that Mike Pence has a horse
in the race which is he doesn't want
Donald Trump's policy to look like the
you know what hitting the fan that it is
actually been this episode is sponsored
by blue Chu one of the things I make a
priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and blue 2 can increase performance and
give you that extra confidence you may
be looking for blue to calm blue like
the color blue is the first chewable
with the same fda-approved ingredient as
in Viagra and Cialis it can be taken day
or night even on a full stomach since
it's chewable it works twice as fast as
a pill whenever the opportunity arises
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed doctors you don't have to go to
a doctor's office you don't have to wait
in line at a pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet package they're
made in the USA and since blue 2
prepares and ships direct it's cheaper
than a pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue
chew gum get your first shipment free
when you use our promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma n pages $5 shipping
that's blue2 dot-com promo code Pakman
to try it totally free blue chew is the
better cheaper faster choice and we
thank them for sponsoring the David
Pakman show